-I also want to talk --
Obviously, your parents --
If you're bringing them
to awards shows,
they obviously were very
supportive over the years.
You grew up in Texas
before you moved to Nashville.
And is -- Did you get your start
doing county fairs?
Is that something that sound
cliché but is also true?
-No, that's a real thing.
There's -- Like, I mean,
that's one of the good ones.
That was a good gig
if you got a county fair.
I've played --
-What's a bad gig? Yeah.
-Like, a parking lot
playing on a bale of hay.
[ Laughter ]
So...
-See, that's what I feel lik
somebody like me living
in New York would think people
would do in the South,
and now you're telling me
it's true.
-That's actually really true
-Yeah.
-It would be like
an "SNL" skit to you.
-Yeah.
-But it was real life.
-So you just get a call, and
you're like, "A bale of hay?
Where? The parking lot?"
-"I'm there!
You're not paying me? Cool!"
-And what were --
What were those audiences like
when you were doing
a parking-lot show?
-Um, not listening?
-Yeah.
You auditioned --
This is incredible.
You auditioned for both
"The Voice" and "American Idol."
-Oh, more than that.
-Oh, so you did
a lot of these shows.
-Oh, my God. Yeah. Like,
everything you can think of.
"America's Got Talent,"
"American Idol,"
"Star Search"
when that was a thing.
Um, yeah.
"The Voice," all of it.
And it was all a no.
-Just a hard --
Did you ever get to even the
second tier of any of those?
-Not really.
I have this, like,
very traumatic, vivid memory
of auditioning
for "American Idol"
when I was 17 in Dallas,
where I'm from.
And it was
at the Cowboys' stadium,
and, you know, you don't see
you know, Paula and Simon
and Randy
in the first go audition.
It's like a stadium cattle call,
and you audition for, like
a 20-year-old producer who has
like, probably no music cred
-Uh-huh.
-You just sing for like
eight seconds
and sing your heart out,
and then my entire group
got cut, and they were like,
"Sorry. You have to take
the walk of shame."
And, yeah, I just remember
being, like, 17,
and I had to, like, walk through
the walk of shame
out to the parking lot
and, like, find my mom's car
and just cry on the way home
with her.
But, I mean, it all worked out
-Yeah, it did all work out
-Yeah.
-That 20-year-old right no
is watching this being like,
"Oh, no."
-Yeah.
-"I passed on her?"
-I know, right?
-Yeah.
-But, honestly, like, the poetic
justice of that whole thin
is that now people,
like, audition
with my songs on those shows
-Yeah.
-So I just get the check
in the mail.
-There you go. Cash that check
[ Cheers and applause ]